puede haber salvado su cabeza pero
todavía no está fuera de peligro
boris johnson sigue siendo el primer
ministro de reino unido sin embargo sus
horas parecen estar contadas desde la
votación del lunes en el parlamento
británico una moción de censura en su
contra desde su propio partido
en la que de los 359 diputados
conservadores
148 no le dieron su confianza eso es más
del 40 por ciento de las filas de los
tories una señal de la confianza rota
no hay duda de que la votación de ayer
es un golpe para el primer ministro lo
ha debilitado considerablemente
recuerde que unas horas antes de la
votación en downing street se hablaba de
limitar la rebelión a al menos 100
diputados al final tiene más de 140 que
han votado en contra la ministrade está
en crisis
envuelto en el escándalo del party kate
que hace referencia a esas fiestas
ilegales en downing street en plena
cuarentena se considera boris johnson
como el responsable del mal resultado de
su partido en las elecciones locales del
pasado mes de mayo entre bastidores ya
circulan varios nombres para su posible
sucesor los candidatos más sonados
clijsters la ministra de asuntos
exteriores el ministro de salud ssa
github it y pretty paté la actual
ministra del interior
también hace eco el de jeremy hunt
derrotado por boris johnson en 2019
cuando quiso hacerse con el liderazgo
del partido conservador
así el primer ministro británico está
más presionado que nunca